this morning we are highlighting two
women who are at the top of their game
while 45 of athletic trainers in this
country are women many still have not
broken into the highest level of men's
sports leagues so that's where jessica
cohen and stephanie lugwig come in
they are both making waves in
professional sports jamie yuka spoke to
them and the players that they train
strength
determination and smashing glass
ceilings recently named head athletic
trainer for the portland trailblazers
find more
jessica cohen is the only female to
currently hold that title in the nba you
said five more than i did
no
when you were a little girl this was not
the job of your dreams i really thought
i was going to be the first woman
president and give some of these guys a
run for their money in politics you
still could be i still could be a few
miles away so at the bottom on this one
stephanie ludwig was just promoted to
the same position first get it going in
place for major league soccer portland
timbers the first in that team's history
i'm super proud of myself and it needs
to continue to happen right especially
women in leadership positions this is
more important than me so
i wear that you know with pride both
midwesterners in their early 30s these
women are embracing their roles good any
pain in a predominantly male profession
much of cohen's first season at the helm
was spent helping players rebound from
injury she's been helping me a lot she's
rehabbing my knee you know trying to
strengthen my knee up and just take care
of me so i can get back on the court we
definitely been keeping her busy so
she's going to earn that paycheck for
sure in this world they cannot do their
job if they're not at 100 percent so i
like the challenge of getting them back
to their baseline level prior to the
injury or even to a better place than
before they got hurt the goal for ludwig
is to make sure each player knows she
always has their back on the field and
off sometimes the athletic training room
especially
is some of the most vulnerable space
that an athlete can be in whether it's
they're actually injured or they're
coming in and they're like man i'm
worried that i can't perform my job the
training is the most important and the
game you just take it lightly she's
always here to to help us do you think
she's improved your game oh definitely i
have you on the massage list today these
ladies are tough and tenacious pull hard
but players appreciate their slightly
warmer approach
there you go
bracelet i feel like i could talk to
jessica about anything you know even off
the court mentally
you know that's what she's here for you
know she's not just a trainer a hundred
percent there should be more more women
in the sports industry i think she's
very emotionally connected which is
important women are driven by instincts
right like we have strong instincts i
think that the ability to listen to
those and being given the platform to
actually embrace them
that's where maybe like we can make
positive strides moving forward do you
think there are differences between
female and male trainers
i don't think so i think everyone
naturally gets along with certain people
in different ways not one time did
anyone say how are you going to do this
job because you're a girl do you feel
like you've kind of proven yourself yeah
last spot regardless of gender
regardless of background i just knew
working at this level of sports would be
hard to get to and i just was going to
do it no matter what both cohen and
ludwig see themselves as more than just
leaders in their field they are also
motivators to their teams so up on the
wall it says work every day the way you
want to be remembered i had a feeling
you're going to ask that question
how do you want to be remembered i want
to be remembered as as someone who works
really hard and comes to work every
single day to not only do my best but
maximize someone else's best despite
their amazing drive and accomplishments
there is one more hurdle for these two
powerhouse portland women to conquer
you've never met stephanie i have not
she wants to meet you we just ended they
just started hopefully there's time
where we can meet i'm super excited for
her and also want to congratulate her as
well i haven't had the opportunity to to
say it in person yet but you know it's
it's amazing to be in the same city with
somebody who is also a trailblazer and
is pushing things forward do you feel
that portland sports fans should be
really proud oh i think they are i
really do think they are
for cbs mornings jamie yukas portland
oregon
it's a nice jamie yeah i like i like
what she said tony they're tough and
tenacious but they all pointed out that
they have a warmth to them yeah i do
think that there's a difference on that
level when it comes to male and females
yeah i mean i like that they're in the
same city and they've never met it just
goes to show how busy they are well
something tells me that's going to
change david begner package they had a
surprise meeting right there yeah i
thought we were building to that you
know what i did too i'd like to sign on
the wall work every day the way you want
to be remembered yeah that's a good
lesson for all of us we'll be right back